pensemos acerca de lo que podría pasar
dentro de china si el gobierno
permitiera que su moneda flotará
completamente contra el dólar entonces
sabemos que el derivado sería su moneda
y se fortalecería hasta que
artificialmente la han debilitado así
tendrías un yuan más fuerte y tendrías
un dólar más débil quiero ser claro
quiero ser claro que el gobierno chino
actualmente en realidad ha estado
permitiendo que el yuan se fortalezca
lentamente en frente al dólar pero está
manteniendo un tipo de cambio queremos
sólo pensar de qué pasaría si flotara
completamente ahora el derivado obvio de
esto que sabemos mantuvo la moneda baja
permitiría que las exportaciones sean
más baratas creando demanda por las
exportaciones verdad ok ahora ellos
permitieron que su moneda se fortalezca
si ellos permitieran eso entonces sus
exportaciones serían más caras que las
de otros países así podría disminuir la
demanda por exportaciones
ahora bien con menos exportaciones
quizás menos producción en sus fábricas
esto obviamente haría que la economía
china fuera más despacio entonces
tenemos que tener cuidado con esto la
economía irá más despacio pero hay que
tener cuidado como les decía porque
cuando decimos que va más despacio no
significa que necesariamente van a caer
en recesión porque han estado creciendo
a cifras muy altas durante muchos muchos
muchos años y si hablamos de ir más
despacio diría que bajarían a un 45 por
ciento que aún es muy rápido
comparándolo con cualquier otro país
ahora también hemos visto que hay
muchísima inflación en china y en cierto
grado como que indica que el consumidor
chino está listo para tomar el relevo de
los consumidores extranjeros así que tal
vez no vayan más despacio como podríamos
pensar ok entonces esto trae la primera
ambigüedad detrás del permitir que una
moneda se fortalezca
ok si permitieron que se dejara de
imprimir el yuan y empezará a comprar
otras monedas en realidad frenaría
frenaría la inflación y sabemos que
estamos peligrosamente cerca de una
espiral inflacionaria verdad estamos muy
cerca nos han estado reportando de 5 a 6
por ciento de inflación en realidad
podría estar cerca del 10 por ciento y
la inflación va a ser mitigada no son el
hecho de que tienes menos llevan
corriendo por ahí la economía se está
desacelerando
también es cierto porque el yuan se
estará fortaleciendo cuando es más
fuerte les permite comprar importaciones
para los chinos los lo que más lo más
importante es importar los productos
básicos y quizás más importante que eso
sea el petróleo así que el precio del
petróleo caería ahora la pregunta del
millón y que es difícil de responder es
qué pasa con la manufactura china en
general mucha gente argumenta porque
china es capaz de crear su base de mano
de manufactura y es porque tienen débil
su moneda verdad pueden producir a gran
escala será que la manufactura regrese a
estados unidos oa europa quizás mi
instinto dice que no iría a eeuu o
europa porque cualquier cosa que
requiera una gran cantidad de de escala
digamos de producción y una buena
cantidad de mano de obra va a ser
difícil para los chinos competir contra
ellos mismos incluso si la moneda fuera
más fuerte yo creo que esa altura china
va a tener que preocuparse por indiado
por latinoamérica mientras estas tienen
ventajas laborales respecto a china y sí
fueran capaces de tener el mismo el
mismo tipo de eficiencia entonces
podrían ser capaces de dar un plazo por
su dinero verdad estamos reportando de
la cadena academy para la cnc